what is that how do you not know that oh
yeah because I'm I have I don't have the
musical taste of a seventh-grader
okay do you listen to Gwen Stefani to
them do you hear that
yeah that sounds terrible what is that I
don't know but it happened when I did
that steeper last week oh then it's
probably this Mabel oh there you go it's
fine right now
I am I hate fucking cable issues
you go battery yeah don't hate stuff I
got brought in I'm gonna so check it out
yes but sings as a Drake designer
designer yeah god you're such a 7th
grade girl are you gonna go to the mall
later with your friends everyone's gonna
be I get a krump your hair you're gonna
get a good number party yeah
June it's my birthday month no one cares
about that June 9 10 11 I'm an Irvine
spurt Ryan Rudy sperm buying California
at the improv 5 show come on out then
the next weekend June 16 17 and 18 your
Smurf day yeah I'm in Nashville
Tennessee Wow Danny's an West nutsack
New York
that'll be June 23rd its 24th and 25th
July 7 spit Cincinnati Ohio spit on the
dismiss bit since spit to sit and spin
natty it sittings been that e hey that's
where I had the Cincinnati party gonna
go and commemorative you think I'm gonna
go make a video paying homage July 14
through 16 man Diego California yeah
American comedy company yeah and then
July 21st through 23rd
st. jute its Missouri where as Jude
Roarke titties horns that one oh that's
not till September I have
Baltimore and come on me more and come
lumbus Ohio what do we do for Oxnard at
the new one that's that's already got
some nards oh yeah Oxnard's artful baby
I see it no dude she went to that door
though
no no she went to sniff the trash cans
looking for things to do she's bored all
right Jude or Kitty's is not until
September 8th I'm doing Lexington
Kentucky as well as I thought so yeah
I'm not supposed to announce that
Philadelphia her up Delphia Philadelphia
we added a show in November that slut
sanctum
but my Philly show added so you can buy
that now for November 18th who's 19th so
this music is too mellow well I mean
dang just thank you Brian for making
thank you Brian but it's like for a
sweet love making times who says this
isn't a lovemaking show so most of the
focus of this show what is it everyone
everyone does when they listen this is a
married couple they talk about how to
effectively make love yeah guys May 27th
May 28th that's this weekend I'm at the
La Jolla Comedy Store with Matt full
Tron
yeah that's how Matt's gonna open the
show he's gonna come on everybody who's
there and tell him you're her mommy no
come on I'm mixing up the love making
music also I'm working on dates for
cities like Portland oh I'm working on
Seattle
Houston you'll see Dallas the last it's
coming
the last hold your panties that's almost
ready
also if I'm I'm usually the comedy store
every Saturday the 7:30 show but not to
see me not deciding because I'll be in
La Jolla the other comedy store but come
come to that Early Show it's been full
of mommies every weekend on Saturday and
it's been so fun that's what's up and
I'm usually in the hallways you can say
hi to me and you'll see like there all
the famous convenience everybody's there
yeah that's great oh listen to that's
deep bro please please if you you know
if you want and then use our amazon
banner to do your shopping go to your
mom's house podcast calm click on the
banner at the bottom of the homepage do
your shopping as you normally would and
it just kicks back some change to the
show thank you for everybody that's
already been doing that we really
appreciate it yes and we see it you buy
printers you buy Lube you buy socks you
buy everything don't tell them that
nobody wants to know that's exactly what
the email said but but we don't see who
buys it no we don't see who buys it but
we're saying we see items that are
purchased through our banner yeah we're
saying keep buying they're a lot of Lube
a lot of Lube yeah that's so funny
there's a lot of dry pussies in the
audience or at dry hands or assholes are
assholes that's true asshole asshole how
do you say asshole
because we have a lot of bears that
listen do we we have a huge bear
community how do you know that judging
by our fan mail baby I don't get a bunch
of bear fan me yes you do you know no if
we convert a quarter of that fan mail to
your mom's house listener ships oh my
goodness babe you're huge in the bear
community how many bears only tours have
you done
yeah seriously what are you gonna do
bears only for real bears only what do
you mean just do shows tailored to the
bay the the gay bear market look man I
just all I gotta see is that check you
know if you guys hire me I'll come to
your bear your bear show yeah you know
just fuckin place when's the retarded
act coming I know you want me to tour as
a retarded retarded retarded economic so
I'm just saying that there's a market
out there that's not been tapped into
and I think that retarded people need to
laugh - okay babe you ready to get this
going
aha oh we should mention there's no
cameras rolling oh right blue band got
sick I know I did that thing where what
people do when they they want permission
to be sick you know I know which I've
done that too and it's and then I've
gotten other people sick by doing that
he was like I'm not feeling so good but
I'll be there I was like no I don't do
that no no all right
feel better blue bands y'all better blue
band his little his feathers are sick
and yes to stay in his nice nest and
just kind of drink warm worm tea and
yeah he's nuzzled up in his nest other
Birds blue bit all right here we go hi
how are ya
join us it's Jason Carr coming out to
enjoy some salad I might be you have mus
you have been very impressive Kelly
we love everybody wants a yoga girl
right Jason that's right I know you want
me to sell it to this welcome to your
mom's house
fuck okay dan is retarded
ah shit ah shit man
yeah how great was that that was on one
of those morning news shows yeah which
is so painful yeah the ones that I've
been going on lately where they have
yeah always have a cooking segment like
I write this morning and this ladies I
guess in town and she has the you know
they they're making salads and then I
guess she's a yoga person and she's
having a shirt that says 7 greens I
don't know but yeah a news guy walks
over she just she starts to get kind of
flirty all right yeah coming down to
enjoy some salad I might be you have
mess you have been love everybody girl
right Jason that's right girls huh he
totally shuts it down to he looks away
he's like he doesn't well no he's like
he knows that that's trouble you know he
goes instead of like having fun with it
he just I didn't hear it said that boss
I didn't say nothing yeah
I guess you're not even allowed to laugh
right yeah cuz that encourages the bad
behavior that's the words this is an
adult and you can't even laugh it man
and she's actually no she didn't say it
I don't think to be like you know to
make that joke yeah she really was
making it with making the other girl a
salad so when she tells him that he's
like it's so funny to me that that
exists in the world where adults have to
restrain themselves I just don't
understand it I struggle with it you
know I used to work in a law firm and
that was the hardest thing in the world
was to restrain myself constantly they
just really really shut it down right
yeah you can't have fun ya know you're
not supposed to laugh at your job or be
inappropriate yeah obviously duh very
sullen man I did so painful was it could
you imagine working on a morning show
how fucking hard and horrible that would
be for one for us Wow I can't wait to
see you salad mmm the big part of the
show is spending time just you spend
time fake reacting the things yeah they
have to go like that's new it's like
spending time with a toddler like wow
look at your salad see how much that
takes out of you just I like that a
second I know but maybe some poop but
maybe some people are like that normally
is that someone's real personality it is
some people's but even then they it
becomes their personality because they
manufactured it for a while yeah no
one's born like that they're like that's
good great over on Main Street okay is
that yeah is that socialization like I
grew up in a house where if I'm not
happy all the time yeah I got in trouble
is probably or maybe it was just yeah
don't show feelings
it was so bad in my house growing up
I overcome and save everything like
that's great yeah cuz feelings are
dangerous feel good you'll get in
trouble well they're like that on the
unmooring shows a lot you know oh my god
that's that's the weather it's local or
even national the Good Morning America's
and those shows it's always like maybe
that just puts people in a good mood you
know you wake up and they're like going
to work and they turn that on someone's
like hey this is really neat what's
going on here today it may be for the
non cynical person oh yeah maybe for
normal people
that's like cheerful feels good that
doesn't work for me that work for me you
know what I don't understand either are
people who want to be Miss America
that's another limit right why why is
that even a thing for you I want to be
Miss America you're so gonna win this
year we're practicing your answers yeah
the best is when they have like the
hardest part for them is answering one
question what was the big it was with
fucking Steve Harvey this year no no no
that's yeah that's his house the best
what's the big fuck up with the answers
remember the girl who lost her mind in
the answer no you don't remember that
wait what do you like she bluffed she
flubbed in her song yes
she's like kill all the Jews I'm I don't
know what I'm saying
yeah Hitler was right it's 2007 it was
Miss Teen USA oh no poor girl polls have
shown 1/5 of Americans can't locate the
US on a world map why do you think this
is
I personally believe that us Americans
are unable to do so because some people
out there in our nation announce and I
believe that our education like such as
in South Africa and the Iraq everywhere
like such as our education over here in
the US should help the US or should help
South it should help the Iraq and the
Asian country so so bad it's hard to I
heard my house for that whole thing I
said he would look at the screen I
wonder if you asked her the same
question today if she'd have the same
response she wouldn't she wouldn't
there's no way do you think she's gotten
over there correct response a few times
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think the next day
it was it must have been just genuine
panic yeah like just a panic moment she
just pin she didn't she blanked and she
had no idea you know she did you have
that and stand up the first few years we
were like I don't even know what I'm
saying I'm so nervous it's like or it's
when you just press play on your a and
you go like why I'm just gonna go say
what I'm saying she she was nervous and
she's young that's miss teen but I know
that the older broads they practice she
said the Iraq and they don't own Maps
okay but the older broads they rehearse
the questions don't they give you so
you're rehearsed yeah and that to them
is the most nerve-wracking event is
having a talk that's that's the funniest
part to me is that's the challenge they
should do blow bangs that does I agree I
think the ratings would pick up
significant Miss Nebraska
here's six guys who talk what you start
with first I'm miss Pennsylvania and I
can suck six coccyx when I take the
challenge
Wow really there should be a porn parody
of that where they do that you think
there is yeah there has to be a Miss
America porn Google it up it's a great
thing Miss America of course they're
crippled ex parody where it's like if
you want to win you've got to blow the
judges yeah that's exactly right sounds
like you're right for these yeah I don't
see it I see parodies but but you don't
here's the thing with Miss America don't
do you win like a you want a small
amount of money it's not life-changing
it's not like you win million no no no
but it's the exposure if you if you play
that exposure right it's also dwindled
it used to be a big deal yeah you know
that would be that would be front-page
news the day after and Maya they would
parade her around on everything people
just don't care about any as much
anymore I think a big part of that has
been that porn that no the feminists
push of the last year the growth you
mean that where they go like wow I've
seen as silly now because so many women
go this is silly it's women so we're
saying that's it well that and I think I
think there was a time in America were
the only the only place you could see a
hot chick in a bathing suit was during
the Miss America pageant yeah you know
like maybe in the 50s you're like oh
shit everybody get their dicks in their
hands the Miss America pageant's on and
now it's like there's porn there's lad
mags there's there's so much exposure to
my ad mag this isn't that what they're
called I don't know where do you live
FHM and Maxim they're called loud man
I'm from um oh they're called chavs
somebody wrote in those boys that talked
like like have horrible do their accent
master of accents this car is a BMW it
lifts off mate this car moves I've never
driven a car like this why do you have
to make your teeth kind of buffed out
because they do yeah yeah I'll Paul
English
people have left all may be using the
Queen of England Todd she does I'm the
queen of England
the Queen of England tear on the Queen
Mum everybody I start Drake dirty now
that was she does she dictates tea time
of course every day she tells everybody
Drake y'all fucking tight no wait what
were we saying
Miss America yeah about porno did you
find it no no no but yeah you don't win
a ton of money and mate yeah maybe the
exposure for like a minute people are
like oh you're who cool and you wear a
crown yeah it seems silliness so dumb
it seems so and also it seems antiquated
they feel old like I feel like
Millennials are like what someone's Miss
America what the fuck is Miss America
even bathing suits look silly like
bikinis the style of them they feel
dated you know on the pageant yeah I
feel like they just feel old timing yeah
they should we're like Brazilian I think
they should go topless and then just
write a song yeah yeah like Miss Brazil
yeah I know I should be topless strong
and then a hole in the front of the
front so you can see how they shave
their pee do they keep their the gap
closed but show the hair okay here's how
they should read you they need to remix
it to make it for today's audience they
need to have Miss America like in
Revenge of the Nerds belching contest
yeah ah who can light her fart best
that'd be cool
i I have my money's I'm miss Michigan
mm-hmm and then you know like beer
drinking and stuff like that and then
the blow banging thing and then that's
the last event that's the most important
and
we have Miss Idaho saying she's never
been with a black eye but she's about to
blow eight of them there we go go ahead
over to Miss Universe and Miss Amsterdam
comes on if she's like I'm gonna take
this shit home and she puts candles in
her beaver and does cartwheels yeah yeah
pretty cool man I'm just suggesting it
to them if they want to get the ratings
up because I think the more that we're
exposed to this but I'm gonna play the
more that Miss America becomes like this
is the newest video terrorist playlist
on my channel she would like to know why
check out my is something that I
consistently said in my everyday life
and I feel like maybe I need to
reiterate just maybe I just want to make
a video that I can link people to one of
these don't it's cool I think it is it's
gonna Ritter eight ready right I want to
reiterate what I've been saying wow he
sounds like that Tyler Oakley guy that I
love so much hey guys I have absolutely
nothing to say in the world so that I
got my haha yeah I love it I was like
yeah I cut your hair not like
I'm tired so my pronouns they are
mandatory for interaction with me I
didn't see them until you put him up
yeah okay well I'd say actually he looks
a little like you and that dude a larger
dude he's got a full beard full beard
full must you know a mustache it looks
like a septum piercing with a safety pin
through it which is normal yeah and then
he has your aunt Mildred's head wrap on
after she takes a shower and some
tasteful I make up shadow with the beard
it goes nice and my favorite I think
here as I see either shaved eyebrows or
bleached eyebrows which is a sign of
total sanity that's I've got my shit
horrifying he has he has manipulated
it's uh it's no longer the tank you
bought at the store he's cut it that's
obviously with his scissors to make it
even lower right so it's very low open
tank on the front hasn't waxed the
shoulders lately huh something I need to
do too pal Dakota it's it's a really
neat look so what a look this America
how do you feel so what the code is
talking about right now is that his
gender pronouns are not an option that's
kind of a relief using it's an easel to
everyone ever to say like I don't
understand well then here's the thing
and I if you're not sure what what and
who yeah maybe hold off on demanding
that everyone stay updated with the
pronouns to refer to you as like maybe
hold off until you've decided and then
make a formal announcement and then
stick to it as an adult you know what I
mean what
looking at it right I understand someone
to respect them or their wishes so I
don't have to understand what it is to
be a black person to speak respectfully
to black people I'm pretty sure that you
can do the same for trans people
specifically non-binary people we don't
know that's what I'm talking about I
don't think there's any problem
understanding trans people actually well
there's I don't I'm uh I personally I
understand non-binary as a non-binary
person well I'm I'm this week I am and I
wish you'd respect my pronoun I've been
eating a lot of oatmeal and I'm
identifying I'm opening gendered okay
just if you could respect that I do
respect it okay is there honey on it
sometimes brown sugar sometimes it's
just but it it just depends we're not
like so hard and difficult I mean in
inconvenient like imagine what it is to
be me and then you wouldn't tell me how
hard it is for you to understand me and
my pronouns like wait what wait you
think that's helping and what we do you
think that that's fucking appropriate
stop prioritizing your comfort as this
person over the struggles and the
respect and the wishes of trans people
you're wrong as to shut the fuck up we
don't want to hear about how difficult
being around us and knowing that is but
he's not a trans man he's saying isn't
he saying he's non that is a good point
I mean it seems like it's two different
yeah arguments cuz there's a trans I
understand transgendered I am a man
transitioning to a woman or I feel more
like a woman I'm a man and feel like I'm
alone feeling like he's saying I'm
opting out of both I am non I just
didn't know that that was an either low
time I didn't know either and I'm so
happy for you that you found that
that thank you that is kind of the thing
that is nice for me to celebrate with
another non-binary person is that we get
to blindly say I'm sorry we or we think
you mean they know we but but in your
mind I need you I hope you're not saying
she and you're in your mind on me and
they together are we and we get to we
get to finally be in a place where
people are so focused on genders I know
it's so exhausting I know I never was
like annoyed what are you I'm nothing
neither Emily's not going to help you
guys why don't you know that
with that being said change your
language like no one is female and no
one is born a girl
no one is any of that like we are
assigned genders at Birth by doctors who
look at us and see certain types of
genitalia I decide what our identity
will be from there on now that's an act
of violence that should be stopped what
I thought my fucking father that
happened but sex is different than
gender you're assigned to sex at birth
he's saying but the doctor doesn't
assign you a gender identity that's what
you they they certainly do I'm sorry
maybe he yeah I thought it was the other
way I didn't know no it's the doctor so
yeah I totally I'm on board with you dog
I think that it is an act of violence
when a doctor sees your penis and
testicles and says you're a boy you know
yeah no I know I'm not I don't mean the
offend they it's it's just like I know I
guess I'm being really insensitive here
our doctor pulls you out goes oh we got
got a pussy right here it's got to be a
girl I know well how do you sure we
messed up with Ellis we we we gender
identified him as a boy I know I'm
putting him in football outfits and
stuff oh no dude we're messing him up
we're messing him up I conforming to
this agender him up ah shit should we
start referring to him as them and they
of course I don't want to confuse the
kid I would keep playing this video but
I want to tear my fucking ear drums out
so you can we'll put up a link to it
later you know and here's no one no one
wants to hold anyone back
I don't certainly won't deny anybody
whatever they are but I think to demand
that everyone keep to speed with your
gender identity at every given moment
yeah I mean come on
that's a little unrealistic I just don't
know what the proper pronouns are all
the time I think actually the reality is
these are just confused people you know
they're confused these I think that I
think the folks that are like I'm astral
gendered I
no they need attention that's different
I think when someone's like I'm a man
trapped in a woman's body that's legit
like if you're willing to cut a real
deal you even have to go that far I
think yeah people just feel like I don't
want to surgically manipulate myself
yeah but I am in the wrong body I think
that's that's totally but I think it's
kind of it is a lot to ask for you to
look at like me like a guy with a beard
and be like hey man what the fuck are
you why are you calling me a man like
sorry right sorry like your act of
violence right like assuming that I'm a
man yeah you kind of fit all the
checkmarks well a man with yeah man with
eye shadow and I mean still you can look
at the person we were just looking at
most people would assume that's a guy
wearing eye shadow you don't go like
that's probably a non-binary person no
you wouldn't know that why would you
assume that
and I God give us all a give us all a
break give us time to come around to all
the pronouns we don't know the
mainstream doesn't know this stuff no no
you can't how are we supposed to know
yeah god damn it's a lot it's a lot to
ask I wish we could show like my dad or
your dad that video and have them tell
us their feelings well I think I'm
pretty good I think I can sum it up
what's that guy's a fag so you say horse
doesn't guy doesn't know it pretty good
okay dad I think that's what everybody's
dad would say yeah all right skies
effect yeah yeah yeah poor Pete yeah he
is he's in a lot of pain that guy that
guy
quickly looks like he's in a lot of oil
he does he does he's not doing so well
and the nails were painted and he had a
bunch of tattoos on his hands like like
I'm gonna tattoo then they're like weird
marker drawings you know yeah you can
deduce that he's in a lot of pain right
yeah so real real heartbreaking news for
a lot of listeners of the show the not
that not Danny obviously but the hey hit
the the Hitler but wasn't bad girl that
we played last week yeah kicked off of
youtube what yeah why because some
people actually heard her very logical
videos and flagged it as hate speech oh
she added grating fucking boot I don't
know if she was advocating violence but
she was definitely in the in the school
of hey why does this Hitler guy have
such a bad rap yeah yeah well I guess it
would be like Isis putting recruitment
videos up on YouTube
we really don't allow that yeah it's
country well that's that's too bad I was
really looking forward to hearing her
her other work on Saddam Hussein there's
40,000 subscribe oh Jesus she's known as
a valley on and she her she had uploaded
videos of her sing happy birthday to
Hitler and another video on how to spot
a Jew that other charming videos include
why Hitler wasn't evil which is what we
played and how feminists supported rape
by causing the migrant crisis that's her
name value on a valley on yeah al Evie
al ioann she said to be an 18 year old
girl living in Canada she is she patreon
is cousin patriarchy I don't know
like shit the teenager openly admitted
to being a Holocaust denier oh geez on
April 20th patoot she looks like a just
a regular teenage girl like a sweet
blonde blue-eyed no she's got a brunette
so she's obviously not as high up the
food chain she think she should know
that Hitler wouldn't appreciate her as
she filmed herself saying happy birthday
in front of a picture of the Nazi
shitbag as this is how this is written
she had baked four cupcakes decorated
with swastikas hmm geez the channel was
turning out and YouTube said the channel
was terminated by us because it violated
policies against hate speech thank you
everyone
valium I know many YouTube videos thank
you for the cupcakes are delicious
I appreciate your messages of love I am
one of your subscribers I enjoying it
very much at night I would watch your
videos I play with my schnitzel as I
listen to with your schnitzel
do-do-do-do-do Jamie just fixed my my
website he sends back up dead and dumped
so anyways poor evalue
that's too bad she was really doing the
Lord's work really doing something there
man what a nut she's gotta be mentally
ill you think so um I did my own thing
by the way when I was in smear my juice
over the weekend I went on a local
morning show someone's doing their own
thing do it God doing his own thing and
this is one of the great local thing
sports a local sports local shows where
they have the segment like old-school
cheesy music this is the clip that I'm
on
it's like Tim and Eric
with television credits that include
Conan Comedy Central live at Gotham he
does like when they use the old was that
on your website from 92 that's awesome I
did in 2007 why are they what are they
pulling from Wikipedia or something odd
only now look at this dog shit Wow oh my
god this is terrible the backdrop is dog
shit American for this guy doesn't have
an upper lip let's stop there Jesus
sends a lot of time onstage and this
weekend is destiny USA so we welcome
good morning
Mercer shout out to the Bristol stool
chart I have number five that soft blobs
with clear cut edges cuz I need fiber
there you go now right away I got a
Bristol stool chart in there it was
fantastic yeah I'm like how the guys a
little nervous and the woman's laughing
mm-hmm that guy's a little she was
really fun yeah she plays she played
along
he was like first of all your outfit
looks amaze I have on a black of course
faux fur
yeah coat people who asked me is that
faux fur yeah you know you should tell
me paid $10,000 well yeah I never mink I
would say that if they ask me on the air
but yeah for the real mommy's real money
is only led by your chain that's real
shit about to get up here again are
expecting a blizzard and Syracuse
obviously now it's just how I roll my
number like this in July I don't care if
it's humid I don't care if it's a
hundred and five Manning up your Emperor
because there's an old saying happy hos
eat sad hoes don't and I try to stay
happy he likes plug yeah yeah she's fun
so you work well she when I showed up
she goes she goes oh I know this DJ dad
mouthing I'm excited oh that's funny
weeding and instagramming before the
show you know hashtag DJ dad mouth look
up is that what we should call you I
mean I appreciate it I'm gonna be doing
stand-up but
my focus is on the after party always so
I'll be tweeting out a location for a
surprise Oh pop-up show and YouTube both
invited that's like a bonus freebie
Friday yeah party like that so um so
with DJ dad mouth I have a question for
you yeah random question okay Weisberg
Kreisler so fast i love she loves the
name a little that's the best Chrysler
Kleiser that's a good question
Liseberg Chrysler so fast
Chrysler cars are so fast yeah Brandon
question Weisberg Chrysler so fast guys
let's do this let's do this you know the
mommies following is strong and we have
as a community because of the strength
of the fellowship on this show we've
made some amazing amazing things happen
you guys we related brace gigolos we
landed Gloria as Stefan just because of
how many of you tweeted her yeah how
about we all this week tweet at Burt
Chrysler who also goes by Bert Kreischer
just ask him why are you so just that I
want him to wake up Wednesday and log on
to his Twitter and be like what the book
just a stream of a thousand thousand
people have tweeted him why are you so
fat
first an alcoholic and he's not he's
diabetic
and he's on a lot of medication and he's
just as sad he's a sad ho but we were
just talking about sad hos I supposed to
not eat but he's so sad he's extra and
that's why we're so fat what do you
think's coming next million dollars
what's the meaning in life aren't
married to a comedian do you guys make
each other laugh all the time what are
you talk about you are married to us
weird comedian so is it like just
totally hilarious and really low look at
my reaction to that question deadpan DJ
deadpan it's a hate not a lot of laughs
man a lot of smells smell your house
that's one kid yeah I mean there's a lot
of action in the home too you know
like I got I got kids that she doesn't
know about so sometimes when she's out
of the house I'll bring other kids over
that are older than our baby they kind
of play in the house when they leave you
know how it goes and speaking of house
let's talk about your mom's house Yeah
right your mom's house that's a lot of
fun it's the best man your mom's house
podcasts it's where you know it's kind
of like it's I feel like it's the Bible
for a lot of people you know there's we
cover up the important issues you know
like like what
farts we cover you see that was just
such a straight face Mercer was the
director oh yeah
so they said he said something before
we're old and I go who's that
she was eyes Mercer he's our director
okay that's why I shot at him all kinds
of stuff man we cover what was the thing
this week
and I I never had a job in my life so I
started doing this you know I've been in
and out of jail now you walk around with
fur
my sensei Segal I was telling me about
that the Buddha nature is just to be in
the moment
so that's what I'm trying to do right
now I think you're doing it really well
actually she's living in the moment if
you want to join town funny she's really
a moment you can do to get it I like 30
and 9:45 he said I wish she was with you
tomorrow night 7:30 9:45 special
engagement for tickets give them a call
for two three she's missing something
nice or visit the man he's dead funny
man Saturday 7:30 show is almost sold
out the full video of DJ dad mouth in
the spotlight this one is called is your
mom is on YouTube and go to our YouTube
page your mom's house podcast and
subscribe we also should mention that
not only can you see all the DJ dad
mouth appearances on our YouTube page
but that we are now releasing classic
jeans yeah once a week on YouTube so
those are the original episodes people
asked us for them all the time and
they're gonna we're starting with
episode 1 well shut up yeah
oh no how embarrassing and is this back
from red band-aid yes oh he said it's
cool oh my god so some of these were
videoed back in the day some of them
were yeah yeah okay Wow so this is gonna
be yeah this is going to be how fucking
horrible where are we in episode 1 I bet
I'm a ferris already no I'm saying
that was the best one yet I like that
best I feel like you perfected how to do
it now like now you got your groove it's
all it's all your mom's house nonsense
yeah and then they have to roll it's
really funny how people react to it who
are not who are who know who know me
from a stand up yeah not the podcast
they're like they'll message me like
what the fuck is this you know they
don't get what's going on yeah it's kind
of the enjoyment though is it's it's an
inside joke but it's an inside job with
like a few hundred thousand people yeah
who other people are just like what is
going on
it's pretty crazy the podcast is really
growing it's really kind of bizarre like
now I go around and people are like
mommy and I went to like a baby shower
and some total stranger was like I'm a
huge your mom's house man yeah what
happened to me at the airport
just mommy's just red so crazy it's cool
it's crazy because we started the show
just in a shitty you know in our shitty
house in Silverlake with a Lithuanian
neighbor you know like it's just neat
that it's grown to something and we
would drive over to Carl's Burbank berm
yeah and do we do the first we did the
first 40 episodes at red bands place
that's right a few of them were done
that's right at the Icehouse studio and
but most were done at UH at red bands
when we started we would do one and be
like next month we'll do another one
yeah there was no schedule you know yeah
and then we learned that that was
important to drop it on the same day
then people don't know how to find you
stuff and those classic jeans are gonna
be released every Thursday on the
YouTube channel cool there is a schedule
for that there's always something fun at
the YouTube channel there's like behind
the scenes there's and on top of that
patreon launches June 1st so if you
don't know patreon is gonna be our new
All Access added bonus content
subscriber based a site that we do
behind the scenes stuff and we do extra
episodes we have one banked that is
gonna come out in June that you can only
do if you sign up for patreon you
basically do like a small you pick your
monthly donation and based on the the
donation you
access to different things so it's a
cool thing it helps us you know keep
doing the show and and you'll get you'll
get access and you'll get extra content
one of things we're definitely going to
do is watch Steven Seagal movies and
comment on those but the first one was
just a cool episode we did we answered
fan mail questions yeah it was fun
alright patreon Hydra hey can we do my
Persian voicemails yeah so tell us what
happened with the first with you got
more voicemails right well yeah they
kind of kicked into high gear this
weekend I'm not sure what happened here
I've saved them I've I've actually had
to put this number in as a contact now
because I get so many yeah I've gotten
one two three since Wednesday let's hear
it's called Persian you take it out of
that take it out of the case I've had
two I call it personally you know cuz
like I get so many and Shahnaz has been
getting a lot of job offers in Texas and
she's not getting those what about Edith
so eight is we actually found out his
real last name because somebody tried to
log on you look them up and I looked
ADIS up one first and he is exactly who
I thought he would be like he looked how
I thought he would
he's like a hipster dude with like a you
know like a white guy with an ironic
kind of t-shirt and look so the first
one is last Wednesday right yes it's
under Persian lady and it starts on
Wednesday to be more reasonable yeah
anyway unnecessary you to you know take
care of your thirty or hopefully doing
good also causing Iranian what the fuck
man how are you doing good and Solomon
never calls you back never never never
no I don't imagine so so I might add a
big say to come back in the corner hall
this is the Thursday one when that was
Wednesday before Wednesday before his
Thursday Thursday yeah
thank you go out
I am in hi mommy Thunder ambition jacks
well welcome for every bed in the corner
close that door in Rahul by micromax
ecology does any man who wrote enjoy a
shindig you let us know by some let me
know what are you feeling what are you
doing what's up various really come at
me come in and we came arrested I'm
coming back to you from the kitchen I'm
telling you follow me
call me to tell yourself call me if you
need anything call me okay but isn't
there a point is why I keep saying is it
there's no point
there are all these phone calls when you
never get because she never obviously
gets the call back there has to be some
point where maybe she sees Salome and
then at that point isn't it like isn't
there ever an exchange about hey you
know how you get my message about this
yeah but I told you that yesterday and
then you don't might happen is that
Salome might be so sick that when this
person sees Salome and mentions that and
Solomon goes you didn't fucking call me
they go totally so crazy right now she's
she's got dementia she's you know
doesn't even know that I called her
earlier well I see I think Solomon is
our age you think so yeah for some
reason I think this is a maternal figure
to sulla me and this might be like a kid
and that's why I've always pictured
Solomon's old no I think Salome is
younger and that's why she kind of
forgives I think it's a boy to a pass oh
you know Salome he's always out having
fun and then here's Friday yeah I mean
every bottle hurry down like one life I
mean it and EE and relief like Alice
here in new material but it does clean
all the bacteria than a memorable
evening Massacre hospital should hold on
I'm good I'm back to normal again I have
any Buddhist sorry we give your college
so it should work on your core issue
before I don't know whichever one it's
fun together of all the bacteria on your
body and some if it is from inside you
as the holiday I'm telling you my little
piece yet okay
yeah see it's it's a hmm I think she's a
journey it's gonna get rid of all the
bacteria on your body and for me if he
is from you saw you at the holiday I'm
telling you I'm a little put it over the
years in one life in magicJack he has
lots of information you can give you
right and can you take care of on a year
subjects and shits all that you see
right there the answers part like
motherfucker that's four hundred
messages crying well the thing is
they're clearly communicating in between
because she knows Salome is not feeling
well and it's a bacterial infection and
and she keeps asking about the lease
this is the second or third thing about
a lease agreement so maybe he's in real
estate or something or they're renting a
property she's kind of it bacteria
though man you gotta get rid of that
bacteria from the inside out
I like that you specified that from
Tommy Sullivan no me
take the fucking pills no Solomon you
should tell your mom that you changed
her number buddy yeah should we call
Persian lady back
I think at this point maybe we should
just do it on your mom's house what we
do right now I'm so nervous what do we
say I mean do you want to just we
shouldn't keep this going solid me it is
sick okay all right let's call the
Persian lady oh my god all right I'll
see what happens so nervous talk to her
I feel like we know each other I know
she's not answering
shit she doesn't recognize Skype number
I know I'd say let's call from my phone
but then how do we record the call
Wow that is our fucking voice that's her
voice really appealing message three
meows dude are we being pranked maybe
it's somebody fucking with us
that could be give me your phone when
driving your phone yeah but then we want
to record the call in case so let me
answer she answers well we should not be
able to it we can't record this on for
your mom's house we can't how can we
record I don't understand why that
wouldn't record them wait if you call
from my phone I don't know shit I think
it would still drink
oh you're plugging in oh I see what
you're doing yeah then try that yeah
dude that was the craziest fucking
voicemail ever three meowt's this
woman's out of her mind that's why she
doesn't know if Salome calls her back
that's right she's fucking crazy dude
that's so true let's see let's see if
this works
I know man oh my gosh wait are you gonna
are you gonna do it on my own
speakerphone
oh there you go hello have to wait for
someone to pick up first before you say
hello dad no I had the I pushed the
buttons oh you're not going to answer
Solomon well now here's the thing we do
yeah we totally just called dad
yeah we just kept making now some of me
shit we just tried to put an end to it
now we've made it way I was gonna get a
definite fucking voicemail like I'm used
to fucking gone yeah three meows three
meows man and I feel like it was her
making the meow sound
I only know as a cat you know babe I
don't think that was a chance
Jesus oh it's crazy yeah she's real
crazy
I was intense
that my friend Sara could be burns are
you doing this she's a big meow meow Mix
Edie downstairs I know we got to play it
one day we've made that years ago I know
when we were touring yeah we actually
went into a recording studio and miaowed
songs with Sarah burns it was fun they
still remember me when I went back to
record to like do my comedy up my second
one feel like I remember you you did the
meow songs hey can we talk about my shit
yesterday okay what you act like we
don't talk about the stuff on the show
Brown okay
I just have a question for you sure so
okay I'm gonna explain the situation and
then you kind of tell me your thoughts
on it mmm like I'm gonna walk you
through it so I was alone with Ellis it
was Sunday morning you hadn't come home
yet right
and I drank my company it sound like I
was out drinking you were out getting
hammered party had you come home yet
hadn't come home you're worthless guy
and then I drank my coffee so I usually
get my cup of coffee ready I drink it I
go in to get Ellis in the morning I wake
him up I feed him I diaper him I bring
him downstairs and then I feed the dogs
anyway I go into Alice's room and I've
already I'm like three quarters of the
way through my coffee I don't really do
that normally I feed him and just as I'm
about to change him I feel the urge to
shit the problem is and you know this
since I've given birth is that I have a
really hard time holding in my stools
and that they go it's immediately will
have to shit no I really have the shit
and so I was like panicked trying to
change his diaper and like I change him
and like oh my god oh my god I'm gonna
shit my pants I didn't know what to do
my back was hurting so I couldn't just
put him in the crib and go shit because
my back got fucked up in tennis so I'm
like oh my god what do I do so I hurry I
diaper him I you know read downstairs I
put him in the swing I strap him in and
then I go take a shit downstairs right
and it was a lot it was like a number
four and it was like - number four logs
you know there here's the problem I went
to wipe and it was like a fucking like a
melted Hershey's kiss in the toilet
paper
it was so gnarly like you know when you
do that first wipe and you're like oh my
god yeah oh my god that is so much shit
yeah and normally I would just go in the
shower and fuck my stoma yeah but
thankfully the day and I just bidet the
shit out of it and shit out of my shit
and then I wiped it clean but why do you
think that happens to me do you think
that that's a post-pregnancy thing does
that happen to you ever
well first of all I just want to say I'm
really glad you asked this question and
I appreciate all the details they matter
because it was because I held it in a
little bit longer than I normally would
I think I'm out unless yeah that's
interesting I think you know it's a real
nice the that you that you told us all
those details but it's pertinent to the
case Brown lock it's not like random
good point yeah I think it's a
combination of you probably you were you
said you were holding it in you're
probably drinking coffee yeah and you
know maybe maybe the a little bit of
what you ate at the previous meal do you
remember do you recall what you ate yes
counselor what did you have well brown
Livius Neal Brown Locke I went to a
vegan baby shower our vegetarian baby
shower and I had a lot of different bean
varieties and I think that may have
contributed mm to my powerful for yeah
and the coffee to definitely contribute
coffee makes a different holding it in
I think the holding it in was really
what you're saying is yeah it's a
combination of things holding it in is
gonna make it worse wait but why is the
wipe it wasn't diarrhea so why was the
wipes so unclean that's like I'm serious
why am I not pinching off the love no
clean it was probably much like it was
Mooji you didn't have just normal logs
right no you couldn't have
they were fours they were perfect I mean
ORS are perfect
is perfect logs they were a little
hotter than normal but I don't know but
yeah they're an exemplary for like if
you kind of look at this they were a
little hotter and a little more torn
yeah but that heat is means that they
weren't perfect because perfect ones
aren't hot hot indicates that it's a
little higher up on that scale you're
probably looking at like a 5 and a 5 and
a half they weren't broken pieces they
were solid yeah but if their heaters
like that that means something's up that
you know you can always tell the heat
factor means this is not 100% and I
think it probably has to do with the
fact that you were having a lot of
veggies yeah and I'll tell you what
happened to me I was in smear my juice I
had three for meals
yeah had a vegan restaurant and I gotta
say I really enjoyed it men really
really enjoyed it that well it was it
was good food yeah and I didn't do it
because I was on some mission to eat
that way it was purely out of
convenience and then it was good so I
stayed at a hotel and right next door um
let's see I'll see if I can plug the
place so yeah back to you but what
you're saying that the log was a little
hot and torn and that's why it just
wouldn't break clean because of the
texture my heart's like strong hearts
Cafe is where I went but I'm asking you
it's the texture of the log you're
saying something I could clinch it off
it just leaves behind
yeah mush yeah you had what you had mud
but and then I know those I know those
you know the they were real blessing in
the skies was though what's that that
you were home I know
cuz then you're wiping and wiping and
wiping and then somebody goes can I eat
your mask you go you sure you want to do
that right what happens every night the
Persian ladies calling
the Persian ladies calling back Oh
oh my god oh my god fuck how do my phone
just shut down so weird
fuck we're definitely gonna have a
voicemail right now anyway so the
phone's starting tell me more about your
Braun story and then we'll go back well
so I ate these vegan meals right first
of all when I give a plug to vegan
eating for a second yeah they were
delicious meals I think I said strong
hearts Cafe in Syracuse smear my juice
and secondly because when you eat vegan
and it's good you just feel good I was
feeling good after meals
that's so happiness right you know
there's no blood there's no like when
you travel yeah Road food you can even
go to a great restaurant I'd be like oh
god oh yeah so much you know heaviness
do you know the truth of it is the less
you eat the better you feel and the
lighter you eat more veggies more fruits
but she's real she's left a voicemail oh
okay let's hear it but I do want to say
this I didn't have crazy dumbs really I
had a lot of farts huh dude it's
shutting down again
that's weird this so but you didn't have
a crazy dump after four vegan meals yeah
isn't that crazy I think you need to
wait a little bit
mmm because you really react poorly to
veggies great but I didn't I'm saying I
had normal bowel movements but farts I
mean that's a neat story yeah I mean it
was it was noteworthy can I tell you my
favorite new game that Ellis plays with
us is pull daddy's beard it makes me
laugh Florida's I hug me when he hugs my
face so funny takes both hey he has a
strong grip and he pulls me towards him
by my beard it's so painful and the only
person on earth that
wouldn't punch in the balcony it is my
son everybody else I would stab
immediately but he pulled me I'm like oh
it's so funny drags me and then his
mouth so something's going on with this
when i plug it in it shuts down yeah
Mikey try it again that's bizarre
but that's happened twice right now so I
wonder what's going on let's see you
it's shit so how are we gonna play
Salome if it shuts down everything No
okay he didn't shut down right there
okay um let's see she's gonna be pissed
oh she's gonna be pissed here we go see
not playing about there yeah she left
for a second voicemail but it's not
playing hello mate I Montgomery my
religion and their bacteria I did it not
plain bacterial infection is it on you
no no the line is working it's so weird
I'm not playing gosh see this is why we
need blue band here take unplug it and
push play and put it up to the
microphone okay
Oh again it started it again no no no
the pop yum sternum a measurement Moslem
mezuzah bazoobs Abbas Abbas ah thanks
for playing though shish kebab and
kebabs who knows why I'm gonna try it
try on yours oh my mommy let's see okay
Persian lady boys an ad by the body
oh yeah it's weird now it's not playing
yeah well fuck it
okay well let me restart the phone maybe
that'll help oh well hold on give it a
minute my phone still like starting okay
I'm not complaining it's definitely
gonna be like solid right what the fuck
yeah she's gonna go buzzes oh what the
fuck
fucking call back okay let's see if I
can play another one in the meantime
yeah so if you really are looking up
your fart game yeah
maybe house King a stripper doing we
haven't really checked in with him in a
while
oh it's been a long time been a long
time he's uh I mean he's still the
master I don't know she on YouTube where
is he kicked off right now he always
goes back and forth man let's see
YouTube see if he's there King uh
anyways I love Alice's new game with you
ash it makes me laugh so hard did I love
that he just tortures you so funny and
then he pulls my hair too which is
awesome
every time you lean it down to give him
as herbart he pulls your hair it's so
fun get to sign in to see this one it's
always a good sign yeah let's see well
we have to sign in know me I don't me
can we talk about look if she calls back
yeah just answer I'm speakerphone you
know I think he's missing Oh Dan that
was a ROG here as far okay yeah this is
King at River unofficial so I don't
think that's his page we don't subscribe
you wouldn't go he wouldn't go by that
let's see here he is I love it
those setups are the best I know he's so
clever yeah well he the only thing that
sucked about was China he was like the
Loch Ness monster because it was
switching accounts always an under a new
name hairy and gross gang a stripper the
fart God or whatever you know he's
always something and I wish we could
just lock down where he's at
you know well you know some people don't
want the fame and the glory that being
on your mom's house brings okay yeah
yeah we have made people famous on the
show and maybe he doesn't want that kind
of spotlight the limelight but don't you
feel like he was doing that before he
was on there like he was always
switching accounts
I don't yeah maybe he's crazy yeah not a
normal because what was the other site
that used to have him all the time
liveleak liveleak well let me see if I
can play this hold on now my voicemails
fucked out yeah oh it was I fart in yo
face I used to be his his thing huh man
it's like yeah it's true it's really
like trying to track down like a
mythical creature or something no well
that's the beauty of him that's let's
see if he's back on there nope the
account associated with this channel has
been terminated for copyright
infringement what that was that possible
his farting that are they trying to say
that those aren't his farts I doubt she
actually got the door though she's gonna
yeah I don't know she's just sniffing
though mm-hm that's not an I have to pee
snip we just had to replace a couch
because of her his fucking dog you know
that we just got the new couch on Sunday
cuz she ran she took a pen and inked up
a brand new couch so he got in living
room inked it all up by chewing it on
the cushion and literally is wrong and
it was the I'll tell you of you know
every time
you buy something now and people go oh
do you want a warranty you know they try
to sell you if you buy if you buy a
fucking an extension cord that Best Buy
they'll go if you want the warranty yeah
you pay this money you're like no dude
but with this couch we did it and the
week or two after we bought it
there's just ink everywhere yeah and it
wasn't actually worth it to have yes for
once and I we replace an entire couch
and thank God we bought that warranty
yeah thank God we'd be stuck with that
couch and what I wouldn't buy another
one no ridiculous yeah no we just have
our ink-stained couch I know and now I
I bought insurance on the the replaced
couch just to me oh my god oh my god
okay what are you doing no idea what
Salome is up to her no one stop playing
mm-hmm well we're just gonna have to
figure this out later and I want to show
you something yeah tell me what you
think this is a armwrestling match okay
it's pretty intense
a little it's really fired up this guy
wear a condom on my tongue yeah you know
it's fine you get that jacked up now you
don't win whoo
oh yeah this guy's full of rage he's
movie not armwrestling maybe a more
aggressive a sport that you can utilize
it's pretty aggressive for higher body
yeah but he wants to punch him right now
I think this dog he needs out she's
okay okay let me uh let me let her go
all right
the bitch holes you took her out she
went p2p let's finish this armwrestling
stupid dog I'm really anxious I think
the guy that's losing his gonna lose he
lost the match and then he swung at the
Jesus that is fucking hilarious ray
thrown in the ground oh my god these are
crazy somebody got their panties in the
bunch you know yeah jeez I feel like
that all the time you know aggressive
just like I want condoms on my tongue
there's good down oh you know what
stupid as the master of accidents I'm
always looking at studying other accents
yeah this guy he's Asian but have you
read I'm at the stay away fishing and I
never seen shit like this before okay
yeah there's some black both we've got
fancy
talent watch this shit you never see
Asian people talking black like that Oh
Texas now it's first Shahnaz let it go
of course I'm gonna let it go listen
take this is an Asian guy oh my god
watch this shit watch this shit that's
weird
here he is again now I want you to know
that this man did this shit with
fingernails and I do fingernails for
living he gonna need a manicure after
this shit so the guy is a nail tech
hilarious he's like he's like two
different stereotypes in one
yes amazed it's incredible what is
amazing
you don't see that usually no you don't
see that Asian dudes talking black no
talking black he just sounds southern
right oh no I think he sounds like Madea
I think he's doing a Medea hey you know
you used to watch all her movies like
that and then you haven't and she's not
put one out no you never talk about him
anymore well I haven't had much time
with the kid baby kind of messed up my
Madea watching button you know you and I
got into a show into the Americans and
there's a guy on there Gregory who I
recognize I thought I know this guy's
space man it was killing me yeah I
looked it up and he was in a Madea movie
that's how I know him from as you were
saying that I recognize him too but it
wasn't from Madea you go oh yeah Madea
I'm like no you would know from that I
don't know what's up with Tyler Perry I
haven't heard about I just I just
haven't heard I'm sure he's still doing
a million things yeah he produces very
successful yeah his genes are always up
there
I like the Madea Christmas stuff and I
love Madea Goes to Jail
I think know the family reunion that
one's actually my favorite one that's
your favorite one yeah Maya Angelou
isn't it you know that she's in the Maya
Angelou yes yeah she's like black Yoda
she fucking tells them what's up it's
awesome you want to read some fan mail I
do yeah go ahead
okay hold on oh there we go look at this
guy been using your Amazon link to buy
stuff for a while how about a shout out
for us buying Lube yeah you got it we
that's so weird okay
64 ounces should keep my ding-dong
that's what he says how do you say
amazing thank you Chris thank you thanks
Chris
we got another one I'm a bisexual
polyamorous bear with two boyfriends I'd
be happy to answer literally any
questions also I love your show so much
I would not hesitate to marry it and
make it part of my poly pile smack hound
thanks max yeah can I ask you something
polyamorous bear with two boyfriends now
you refer to them kind of equally two
boyfriends I understand in the
polyamorous community so you have your
primary that's those bits he was looking
right oh gee my my phone case great
usually they say I have a primary and a
secondary but I noticed that you kind of
equate your two boyfriends so how does
that work
I would ask that good question and why
don't you read that third one yeah
when Christina was talking about
European nudity I was just chuckling but
I can say with a lot of certainty that
Polish people both in Poland and living
in the UK would freak out if you were
walking around and just your underwear
nudity is devil not normal
maybe they were in a cult hippie in the
cult slash hippie sounds funny though
peace and much love Millar I think yeah
well listen Milosz I am NOT a fucking
Polack I'm Hungarian and I tell you if
you go to Hungary and you go to the
Gaylord hotel and you go through a
thermal bath which is the most popular
thing you can do in Budapest that you
have to go nude but what milosz is
pointing out is that were really adamant
about European European European
European European Europe us Europeans in
European we are all naked all the time
and telling you that that is not the
case Milosh
also - I believe we're just more
comfortable with nudity and I say that
because look you turn the TV at 10:00
p.m. in Europe Western Europe yeah you
know and there's tits on TV and
commercials for like you know fucking
lollipop commercials there's a girl with
her tits out or whatever
mmm so I'm just saying and there's tits
and magazines like normal magazines in
England by the way those lad mags
yeah they show their tits okay okay so
yeah why don't you read the this one hi
mommy's here - hi mommies I noticed you
guys talking about flippers on a few of
the last episodes so for those of you
don't know what those are flippers are
like retainers what is she doing now
do you hear her of course I was she
fucking knows we just have a destructor
flippers are like fake teeth it's a
retainer with a tooth or two on it and
that's what people do instead of
replacing teeth they will get a retainer
and I had a cousin that did that for a
few years so this person writes I make a
lot of these pieces of shit as I work
for a dental lab you would not believe
what some trashy people ask for with
these things some include gold front
teeth with dollar signs some even want a
picture of their ugly kids put on oh my
god like they're proud to show off how
poorly they take care of their teeth
feel free to ask any more questions you
have in the dental world
I'm also Polly by and when I tell people
at work they look at me like I just
burped in their faces anyway finally a
longtime listener from the days you
lived in the ghetto and your neighbors
stench would come through your walls
yeah it's been so long that's how I
remember the story being a gay man and
having many bear friends see I would
have to say tom is definitely a
California grizzly
here he is very comfortable with his
primitive ways marking his territory
with his boogers and making brown for us
yesterday otherwise we would just call
him a poo bear because he is cuddly and
likes to eat a lot oh my gosh you know
what's weird I was reading Winnie the
Pooh last night to the kid that's one of
them in the story then Winnie the Pooh
sees his friend and I thought you're the
Pooh Bear
you do remind me a Pooh yes yes sir
equine diarrhea equine diarrhea music I
don't know that's weird
I don't know first we have to understand
the characteristics of normal equine
poop capes fecal balls loose stool fecal
balls that have excess water before or
after defecation cowpie watery diarrhea
or even projectile diarrhea projectile
diarrhea projectile diarrhea fecal
matter or fecal fluid that's dried on
the horse's mouth wine diarrhea wine
diarrhea corn diarrhea by an excess of
water or fluid in the horse's stool
that's good let's see another page you
know let's see go old school here oh my
god these are all drilled watch your
profanity
there's the Atlantic Ocean and the
Pacific Ocean but some of you pronounce
specific a specific the word is specific
the ocean is Pacific
some of you sambal any man there's a lot
yeah that's a good one JJ yeah ice JJ
ice JJ fish yeah yeah he's real it's all
profanity Oh
sharkeisha remember it's tricky just
song right there sorry sharkeisha no
sharkeisha sharkeisha no let's go
but he's supposed to be my supposed to
be
he's supposed to be mining it out
sharkish I know but he's supposed to be
mine amazing yeah oh my gosh honestly
you have to wipe down
where did she I forget her name that
citizen Lucy yeah we met her right yeah
do you see I think yeah we actually are
so amazed what is a maze is that you
made that song yeah it was really good
yeah so many funny people who listen to
this show yeah the board so much fun
white tigris and yeah I remember that
yeah so much stuff being we've done the
show those pages time yeah this is so
funny
good choking and gagging is certainly a
turnoff and keeping a great blowjob
doesn't require that you reenact a deep
throat porn scene it's ah do put your
dick between your legs put your dick
between your legs
with the tip of your tongue on the top
right side of the head of his penis
you're gonna cross over the shaft to the
left side of the testicles to the right
there you go back over the shaft to the
left side and then you gotta suck okay
then you're gonna take it to a good time
over the shaft to the right testicle
over to the left
hey did I you mentioned that Tamar is
leaving dude the the tar are the real
the real yeah there's some of the real
or the talk I don't know I can't
remember now you've watched it I have I
you know again having a kid puts you in
a fucking wormhole yeah you've miss out
on everything
but yeah so she was on I think it's the
real Loni love who I love was a great
friend yeah is on that show and then
there's like oh and also what's her name
one of the twins the famous twins from
the stupid Sister Sister show yeah yeah
they're a fucking Boulder's see that guy
was in our old neighborhood and rampart
yeah anyways so she why is she leaving
you're the one who told me well I saw I
saw a an article about it that said you
know they're parting ways they did they
did one of those joint statements you
know about all the pair get out to all
the pyre to all the pair let's see if
it's in this here extend no not there
did I not text to you you I didn't see
the story I didn't have a minute to but
I I you just heard that Tamar is leaving
the view I mean yeah I keep calling at
the wrong show it's the real and I'm
curious to know if it's because she got
a better offer
or she wants to tour I know she just on
Instagram she goes I'm finally back and
she was performing it is real it is the
real but she was she's like I haven't
sang in six months I'm like how the fuck
do you know for six months unless you're
sick or something yeah okay let's see
hey Tony you had a biopic coming out on
lifetime called Toni Braxton unbreak my
heart smell
were you in the creative process you
know outside of writing the book I
didn't want to be involved creatively
because it says by now you probably have
heard that Tamar Braxton has been cut
from daytime panel talk show the real
well there has been major speculation as
to why the singer says betrayed yeah as
to who betrayed her Oh potentially
leading to her getting fired news report
shot may not have been any of her
co-hosts after the day before the day
before the joint statement came out she
posted on her Instagram that she trusts
somebody that she shouldn't have who
betray who would trade her wow I wonder
according to the Jasmine brand all four
remaining co-hosts were blindsided by
the news of Tamara's two-parter a source
said they were completely left in the
dark and are devastated by the news
since they all truly got along behind
the scenes the ladies allegedly didn't
even know a show issue statement was
being put out to the public also even if
the remaining hosts banded together to
stop this decision from moving forward
they couldn't since they each have their
own individual contract which causes
them nabbed if for compensation bomb I'm
guessing it's money yeah it's always
money she probably wanted a lot of money
well blame her she's kind of the the
star you know right yeah I mean because
the the joint statement came out and
said you know we're parting ways and all
this stuff and like we wish her the best
and she was half but it was one of those
things where see earlier this is before
she the statement I love you all but
I've been stabbed in the back by someone
I stupidly trusted not my man or my
sisters I am not about to be tried and
tested to snitch and it's not in a good
taste to tell you who but as you
tarnation's know you're very smart you
can figure things out on your own and
then it goes on and on but but the day
after that she got the boot Wow yeah I
wonder because this is a bullshit
statement here read this statement yeah
this is a
okay this is weekend right here it says
the real and Tamar Braxton have mutually
decided that Tamar will not be
continuing with the show for its
upcoming third season she will be
leaving in order to concentrate on her
solo career everyone associated a real
associated with the real appreciates
Tamar's efforts and the contributions
she has made to the show's success and
we wish her all the best for the future
wow that sounds like some bullshit
noticing how different she looks yeah
she's a lot of work you got a work work
work work work work we got to do work on
your face face face then she looks like
a totally different human she really
does yeah yeah yeah hmm well you never
let me get like that I'm certain I would
be really sad if you did that to
yourself hmm really sad if you did that
to yourself that's just a sign of losing
your mind
hmm see now I'm curious I gotta ask
Lonnie on the down low what yeah well
then you can't report it here though
it's gotta be I got a no I know she told
me that they got along I've heard that
they gonna log on the show I believe
that was just you know unfortunate all
right um
we got to get going here this I'm so
excited to play for you one of our very
talented listeners we get the the name
right here Jordan wolf took previous
salome voicemails and made a song Wow so
here is Salome by Jordan wolf featuring
Brian days and that's gonna be our song
for the week going out thank you guys
very much for listening please go to
your mom's house podcast.com also I
don't forget the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash your mom sounds
podcast new content classic jeans every
Thursday all the videos that we play we
put them up and packed around starts
June 1st don't forget to sign up for
that please go to Tom Segura comm for
tickets to my live shows and go 2,000
ranch comm for tickets to Christina's
tweet at Bert Kreischer why are you so
fat hashtag Bert is fat
let's get that trending hashtag Perez
Ratbert as well
and that's a fat part thanks guys hi
mommy I wanted to know what that Farsi
lady would say buddy John she wouldn't
miss a month the most amazing part of
these messages that Christina keeps
getting non-stop on her phone to me are
that the person who's leaving them
never hears back from whoever she's
contacting whoever you're contacting
hates you like how about you just stop
you guys aren't friends
there's sue there's no love there
I assumed you were message I can today
a different number then you texted from
thank God your text sounds good
cuz I thought that I should
Salome Salome Salome
this
they give you a hard time
Spanish there
oh you bad you forgot her blood pressure
this box
saturation yeah
I can't
then execs did
gosh
No
Randy volunteer for a position
oh man so good that's good stuff yeah
that's good stuff